é eu queria começar com um bom todo
mundo falou de de pessoas eu queria
falar de geladeira falar de outra coisa
que começar com uma pergunta é quantos
de vocês têm geladeira em casa
quantos têm geladeira com internet
ok é foi por volta de mais ou menos o
ano 2000 quando ouviu falar pela
primeira vez sobre a geladeira com
internet
é nessa época eu era trabalhava como
assistente de marketing de uma empresa
que comercializava produtos da cisco
cabos memória de um roteador
nessa época além de assistente de
marketing e era também aquele cara que
cuidava do servidor e da rede
e aí de vez em quando eu quebrava um
galho propor os chefes o dono da empresa
eu ia até a casa dele a configurar a
rede da casa dele era uma rede muito
complexa assim muito avançada para se
ter em casa naquela época mas o que mais
me deixava é interligado era o fato
tinha um ponto de rede na cozinha e ele
falava para mim aí pra geladeira
eu nunca vi essa geladeira instalada
o fato é que numa época pré eo youtube
netflix nest era difícil imaginar o que
de fato daria para fazer uma geladeira
conectada na internet
anos depois se passaram e eu me pego
participando da criação de uma campanha
de uma geladeira que era muito próxima a
essa geladeira com internet com 11
pontos de rede que tinha lá naquela
época ela não era uma geladeira na
internet
e aí passaram mais alguns anos e hoje é
geladeira com internet exemplo em
diversos artigos sobre a internet das
coisas e agora sim eu acho que eu e
vocês a gente consegue imaginar a
atividade para ela a roupa para uma
série de coisas
e por falar em roupa
o principal questionamento quando o
assunto é internet das coisas é isso não
é só um modismo
bom eu não entendo a fundo moda a ponto
de poder discutir isso mas uma coisa que
eu sempre soube é que nas passarelas é
estão aquelas coisas nem tudo que está
na passarela é o que você vai usar na
rua mas é lá que estão as inovações
estão as obras de artes e aquilo que um
dia você vai acabar usando ou pelo menos
você vai ver uma vitrine é eu percebo a
indústria da tecnologia está cada vez
mais parecida à indústria de moda
provavelmente a gente está entrando na
curva do crescimento exponencial foi
muito falado aqui onde o futurista
reitor do eu dizia que no século 21 a
gente não vai viver 100 anos de
progresso vai ser equivalente a quase 20
mil anos
de acordo com uma pesquisa da mckinsey
de 2013
nos últimos anos a gente teve um aumento
de 300% no número de máquinas conectadas
com máquinas e à redução de até 90% do
preço de sistemas microeletromecânicos
nesse momento a gente olha com
empolgação as possibilidades da internet
das coisas
um conceito tão amplo e poderoso que
gerou até um sub conceito tão grande
quanto são usuárias bons é produtos como
google glass trouxeram uso air bus pra
grande mídia e trouxeram essa discussão
eu não acredito que o google apple mesmo
a nike que fez o flu foi band estão
brincando por vaidade dos seus
visionários ou pra rasgar dinheiro né
é primeiro porque não dá pra ficar fora
da busca pela inovação é preciso
é criar é preciso realizar ea velocidade
da tecnologia irão forçar a necessidade
da reinvenção o tempo todo e esse é o
ambiente perfeito para a criatividade e
para as coisas e nem pesquisas podem
comprovar
então seria a moda cada vez mais
tecnológica em seu processo criativo
pesquisa e inovação de materiais ea
tecnologia cada vez mais fashion e webo
curiosamente se a moda é permanente
permanecesse na praia na condição de
prática de confecção já teria sumido do
do planeta como conceito
por isso faz sentido a gente acreditar
num movimento simbiótico onde a moda
torna-se cada vez mais cada vez menos
roupa e cada vez mais tecnologia ea
tecnologia então se ocupa da qualidade
estética ajudando nossa busca pela
identidade através das roupas e um
recente relatório da gartner os
pesquisadores mostram que ambos assuntos
internet das coisas que o air bus
então no auge do seu no pico do seu rap
sayko esse é o momento que empresas
estão criando pessoas estão protótipo
pando
existe uma uma certa demanda para isso
na sequência viria o vale da desilusão
que o momento que essas tecnologias não
entregaram tudo que elas prometiam vida
então cruzou para flight mim que é o
momento em que os pilotos se aparecem e
os investimentos que aparecem e já
começa a fazer sentido para as pessoas
chegando então no platô da produtividade
que a hora da adoção em massa do mesmo
jeito que acontece nas passarelas
esses ciclos vão deixando ideias e rumos
e caminhos você certamente não vai usar
tudo que está sendo criada
mas essa onda ela passa e ela deixa
coisas boas e isso é a destruição
criativa de hoje
esse antigo termo criado em 1801 e colou
mista
ele dizia que novos produtos e novos
métodos competem com os velhos com uma
vantagem competitiva que pode significar
a morte deles no capitalismo isso
significa isso acontece devido ao
sucesso e não ao fracasso
portanto esses ciclos de inovação
produtiva é como eu to falando são
empurrados pelo avanço tecnológico chips
cada vez menores mais baratos mais
desenvolvidos permitindo um volume cada
vez maior de invenções alterando
modificando e muitas vezes até matando
mercados é um infinito processo que hoje
não é somente realizado por empresas ou
grandes corporações mas também por
pessoas comuns
uma boa idéia na mão mão de obra
disponível em rede e fornecedores
globais
cláudio funk em milhares de pessoas hoje
são os maiores concorrentes das
concorrentes das grandes corporações
principalmente por estarem expostas ao
risco e terem quase nada a perder
observe a enorme quantidade de empresas
que hoje estão dispostas a acelerar em
investir nessas pessoas nesses matters
por esses motivos nessa corrida irão
surgir cada vez mais produtos serviços e
soluções para o mundo pára para a cidade
para as pessoas
essa é a oportunidade para marcas
agências para as pessoas programadores
malucos pra mim pra cada um de vocês
realizar porque idéia sem realização não
é nada
eu fiz a minha
isso aqui é um boné e um chip nfc
ele carrega minhas informações cpf e
mail telefone e está conectado ao
facebook e ao twitter
é esse é o momento pra gente pra gente
jazz mais chance ao experimentalismo ao
risco e as idéias inacreditáveis mas
inacreditável mesmo é saber que hoje é
diferente daquele meu chefe
ainda tem quem nem acredito em geladeira
com internet ligado